[Musique]
je
non il a rappelé simplement aux hommes
des principes qu'il connaissait à
l'époque où on éduquait encore les
hommes à savoir qu'il faut être un
gentleman un gentilhomme moi on m'a
toujours appris l'homme propose la femme
dispose des skis et d'original et de
drôle avec les postmodernes avec les
gens d'aujourd'hui où les penseurs
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils découvrent la lune très
clairement le hashtag nitoo a bouleversé
la relation qu'entretiennent les hommes
et les femmes
oui il ya une sorte de suspicion
maintenant d'un côté de la part des
hommes et en même temps toute une série
d'hommes qui étaient des prédateurs qui
savent que leur comportement n'est plus
un comportement comme légitime et puis
ça bouleversé aussi les choses du côté
des femmes qui aujourd'hui ose parler
aux comment dire devenir être être
volontaire
[Musique]
vraiment encore une fois un effet de la
vanité postmoderne de penser qu'avec des
hashtag avec que 3,3 réflexion de jeu
c'est pas de penseurs féministe actuelle
on va être capable de détruire c'est que
l'évolution ce que la nature ou ceux que
dieu pour les croyants qu'on forge et
sur des milliers des milliers d'années a
pas de la base de la base dans leur
niveau le plus le plus intime et le plus
fondamental par le fait de posséder les
femmes et la féminité en sens inverse
c'est justement cette espèce de de deux
façons d'être d'être en retrait de
comment dire de ne pas se donner d'avoir
l'impression qu'on donne quelque chose
si on couche avec un homme par exemple
mais il se trouve que ces deux ces deux
idéaux en quelque sorte virilité
féminité basse et ceux qui sont en train
d'exploser aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on
appelle féminité dans quelques temps
j'imagine est ce qu'on appelle des
réalités aujourd'hui ça ne signifiera
plus ça
[Musique]
aragon était un homosexuel communiste
donc j'ai activement c'est une phrase
quand on la replace dans son contexte
assez drôle l'avenir de l'homme et la
femme natacha polony est écrit que
l'avenir de la prévenir de la femme
c'est aussi l'homme
en fait l'avenir de l'humain c'est ça et
et c'est encore ça le sera encore
demande c'est l'amour entre l'homme et
la femme
voilà la seule phrase est la seule
vérité avec elle je crois si il voulait
dire ça c'est à dire que les les femmes
vont permettre aux hommes de dépasser
leurs complexes viril de des places de
déplacer cette espèce de façon qu'ils
ont eue d'être obsédé par le pouvoir par
la prédation par le fait de au delà de
ce complexe nom de ce complexe cette
espèce de frustration originel d'être
dépassé leur violence la nécessité de
l'expression de leur violence et bien à
ce moment là oui ça voudrait dire que
non seulement la femme va comment dire
c'est en quelque sorte l'avenir de
l'homme mais ça veut dire qu'on
s'oriente vers une civilisation qui
seraient plus évoluées
[Musique]
ça a des conséquences parfois souvent
même n'efface la virilité la viralité
vous savez c'est aussi ce qui protège
c'est aussi ce qui est ce qui est un
plus ce qui est un peu ceux de l'énergie
dans la création dans l' envie de se
dépasser dans la vie de fonder des
choses qui durent qui sont solides et
stables
la virilité à des mauvais côtés ça c'est
absolument certain mais on ne supprimera
pas ses mauvais côtés en recommandations
suspension cherche à tout prix à
mépriser la virilité à vouloir la
supprimer entièrement on se passera
aussi de beaucoup de choses qui nous
permettent quand même à la fois de
survivre et de se développer
je ne dis pas que les hommes sont
coupables en tant que tel puisque en
même temps ça résulte d'une amboise
d'une frustration de toute une série de
choses qui ont pu être analysés par des
psychologues par départ des
anthropologues je dis pas qu'ils sont
coupables jeudi que les hommes en tant
qu'homme sont responsables sans
forcément être être coupable de cette
situation est que cette situation est ce
qu'elle est et qu'aujourd'hui est en
train d'être dépassé c'est la seule
chose qui compte
[Musique]
catherine la grande jusqu'à margaret
thatcher elles ont été souvent aussi dur
sinon même plus plus dur parfois même
plus cruel que les hommes donc je ne
suis absolument pas certain qu'au
prétexte que nous ayons des femmes au
pouvoir la politique deviendra plus
douce plus amènes et plus et plus plus
gentille si je peux l'emploi des mots
enfantins
non l'histoire nous montre que toutes
les shaks fois que les femmes ont pris
le pouvoir
elles ont dirigé de façon très viril et
souvent même de façon très cruel je
crois que si aujourd'hui les femmes sont
plus en plus dominante dans les dents
les concours de c'est juste parce
qu'elles ont pris l'habitude de se
battre qu'elles ne sont pas assis sur
les privilèges des hommes et donc elles
sont plus aguerris et donc les hommes
vont mettre un moment avant de se rendre
compte que maintenant il ya cette
concurrence avec cette population de
femmes plus aguerris qui doit se battre
pour obtenir ce qu'elle doit obtenir
mais ce n'est pas parce que des femmes
seront au pouvoir à la place des hommes
qu'on sera dans un monde meilleur
[Musique]